why is the iron throne suddenly being so
violent does this chair have a mind of
its own or is viserys just accident
prone stay tuned to find out
king viserys targaryen is a pretty
clumsy guy isn't he sure he's a mighty
ruler the patriarch of westeros's finest
family and a builder of scale models
however the guy can't seem to sit on the
iron throne without inflicting serious
and wildly infectious cuts on himself
which seems like a pretty strange
character flaw considering that the seat
is a very central part of his job after
all pretty much everyone who sat on the
iron throne in game of thrones could
lounge on it any way they wanted without
filleting their muscles or appendages as
the people who are familiar with george
rr martin's source material may already
suspect there's a reason behind this
dramatic change in the iron chair's
effects on the person who sits on it and
the reason goes far beyond viserys
targaryen's personal sitting skills in
game of thrones the dangers associated
with the iron throne tend to stem from
the fact that if you sit on it several
factions will attempt to remove you from
it by any means necessary however george
rr martin's a song of ice and fire
series depicts a very different iron
throne the throne was designed by none
other than aegon the first targaryen aka
the conqueror being a tough enough guy
to earn a nickname like the conqueror in
this universe aegon wanted to make sure
that whatever rulers came after him
would be up to the task the iron throne
was created as a combination of a
stealth test and a method for weeding
out the unworthy it's uncomfortable
sharp and dangerous so if you're not as
vigilant as a ruler should be it's very
quick to remind you in the shape of a
cut or maybe five because of the
throne's tendency to cut the ruler who
doesn't have their head screwed on right
martin's lore includes mentions of
several kings who didn't respect the
throne the most notorious one would
probably be maegor targaryen who was so
bad at sitting that the iron throne
actually killed him another name worth
mentioning is the mad king aerys ii who
was eventually killed by jaime lannister
only after he had injured himself by
slouching on the throne even the
reigning awful king joffrey baratheon
cuts himself in the books it definitely
appears that viserys targaryen isn't the
kind of guy the throne approves either
episode one of house of the dragon
includes what seems to be an example of
correct iron throne posture when viserys
banishes damon near the end of episode
one he's sitting straight as an arrow
wielding a sword of his own damon walks
away and viserys immediately cuts his
finger on the throne add that to the
back injury he sustained before the
beginning of the series and it's not
hard to suspect that the character might
not see the end of the show the
dangerous nature of the iron throne is
reflected in its design it's difficult
for a large seat made of swords to be
unassuming but that's exactly what the
original show version is compared to the
new house of the dragon iron throne
there aren't a thousand blades
there aren't even two hundred
i've counted
this pointy jetty thing surrounded by
scores of blades is not the kind of
thing you'd imagine hauling on the
convention circuit for fans to take
selfies in unless they're very very
careful fans after all the house of the
dragon iron throne is even dangerous on
set because there are real weapons
incorporated in its design still while
closer to martin's vision than the
original even the new seat is a far cry
from the iron throne of the books the
book version is an asymmetrical
dragon-sized mountain of bent and
tormented blades the house of the dragon
version still isn't quite there but its
bulky dangerous looking design makes it
clear that this is very different from
the beloved original perhaps someone in
the show eventually becomes tired of
cutting themselves whenever they sit
down on what's effectively their office
chair and commissions the relatively
streamlined and more efficient version
we see on game of thrones
[Music]